there were a couple of stunts i got to
do on the obstacle course which were a
challenge i think freya did an amazing
job of playing that as well our stunt
team joked that they kept trying to like
throw freya out at the end of the night
that she just wanted to keep training
well freya i've got to tell you
siri's journey in season two of the
witcher was by far my favorite part we
saw her go from princess to powerhouse
what was it like for you and what was
the most challenging part of the
training as you really had to step it up
in season two yeah the most challenging
part i don't know i mean i kind of make
everything a challenge because i'm a
perfectionist so i get very easily
frustrated when things aren't going
exactly as planned
our stunt team joked that they kept
trying to like throw freya out at the
end of the night that she just wanted to
keep training and i think part of it is
just because that's who freya is she
wants to get her hands on she wants to
dig in um she wants to be able to try
everything on her own but i think also
it was in reaction to her storyline in
season one which is a lot of running
away from things and i think both as a
character but also as an actor it was
like okay let's push beyond this let's
get to the next step in episode three
she does a huge sort of training
sequence that i think
game fans are especially gonna love
because it really is is from the witcher
3 covers that same territory um and she
did so much of that on her own uh it was
incredible i think there were a couple
of stunts i got to do on the obstacle
course which were a challenge like
having to fall off the beam and also but
i i also love the element of like the
fact that you know siri gets wounded and
then she's having to do the course with
that and you have to consider that in
your mind as you're doing the course so
i don't know uh and and then obviously
there was the sword work which was a
whole new skill to learn and um i really
wanted to get right and uh yeah no it
was i loved it though
so
i'm your destiny
you're much more than that cirilla
and it was so fun to see you and henry
share so many scenes together in season
two considering we went essentially all
of season one with the exception of one
scene with you guys completely apart uh
what was it like working with henry so
much this season and how would you
describe geralt and siri's dynamic
it was fun i mean henry just like i
didn't expect him to but he you know
cracks jokes on set uh which is really
nice to like break up in between the
sort of intensity of what's going on in
the plot but yeah no their their
relationship is you know it evolves uh
throughout the season you know they're
having to navigate a lot with one
another because uh they both got their
different aims siri is resisting
revealing anything to do with herself to
him because she fears those things that
she'd have to reveal
and geralt's wanting to find out so he
can protect this girl
and siri's wanting to become a witcher
uh which is not in line with him uh with
geralt's idea of protecting us what's
going on gerald move
now
he's been through trauma as much as
cyrilla has
and so he's got to recognize that and
give her space to be free with her
trauma as well because people have tried
to delve into his past as well and it's
it's not a good feeling when someone
tries to force you to talk about your
trauma and so i wanted to show that that
aspect of girl that soulfulness that
understanding to say you know what i'm
gonna i'm gonna sit here and tell a
story and if you want to keep on talking
after that then you can
and and i think freya did an amazing job
of playing that as well of playing the
like huh okay well he's been through
stuff too then i get it and maybe i am
comfortable sharing this and i think
freya did a wonderful job of showing the
subtleties of that so it's this kind of
like push and pull there's a lot of
friction at times and there's there's
resentment
you know from siri's side
to him as well because humans and she's
not trusting of people
and this continent after what she's
experienced in season one and what she's
discovering about her family and so
you know they they're navigating all of
this but ultimately build a really like
caring relationship at the end of it